[Applause] in
the evening or good morning I don't know what time he
is there at any time but
I am happy to participate in your
meeting I really liked the title
the feature because while looking to the
future in comfortable life today to dialogue
looking to the future invites you to  turn
to a trustee
the future is made of you it is made up of
encounters because life flows
through relationships several years of
life have made me grow more and
more convinced that the existence of
each of us is linked to that of
others
life is not time that passes
but a time of encounter
meeting listening to sick
suffering migrants who face
tremendous difficulties in search of a
better future prisoners who
carry hell in their hearts
especially young people who do not have a
job often accompanies me a question
why  them that not me I
too was born in a
migrant family my
dad my grandparents like many other
Italians left for the  'argentina and have
known the fate of those who are left with
nothing
I too could have been among the
discarded of today so in my heart
it always remains that
because they and not I would like
first of all that this meeting
help us to remember that we all
need them.  one of the other that none
of us is an island an autonomous self and
independent from the others that we can
build the future only together without
excluding anyone we
often don't think about it but in reality
everything is connected and we need to
heal our connections even
that hard judgment  that I carry in
my heart against my brother and my sister that
untreated wound that unpardoned evil
that rancor that will only
hurt me and a bit of war that I carry
inside and an outbreak in my heart to
put out so that it does not break out in a
fire that leaves no genre  many today
for various reasons seem not to believe
that a happy future is possible
these fears should be taken seriously but
they are not  Invincible can be overcome
if not what we also close in on
ourselves because happiness is experienced
only as a gift of harmony of every
detail with everything even the sciences
you know better than me today they show us
an understanding of reality where
everything exists in connection  in
continuous interaction with the
others and here I arrive at my second
message how nice it would be if the
growth of scientific
and technological innovations also corresponded to an
ever greater equity and
social inclusion as it would be nice if while
we discover new distant planets we
rediscover the needs of our brother
and sister  that orbit around me
how nice it would be if fraternity,
this word so beautiful
at times expels us not only to reduce
social assistance but to become a basic
attitude in the choices at
the political, economic and scientific level
in relations between people between peoples
and countries only education to
fraternity to concrete solidarity
can overcome the culture of waste that
does not only concern food and goods but
first of all people who are
marginalized by techno and economic systems
where at the center without realizing often
there is no longer man but human products
solidarity  solidarity is a word that many
want to remove from the dictionary
but it is not an
automatic mechanism, it cannot be programmed or
commander
and a free response that comes from the
heart of each
yes a free response if 1 understands
that his life even in the midst of many
contradictions and a gift that love is
the source and meaning of life how it
will be able to retain desire to
do good to others to be
active in goodness it takes memory
it takes courage and also creativity
they told me that you sort out so many
people  very creative
yes love and asks for an
ingenious concrete creative response
, good intentions and ritual formulas
that break up are not enough, which often only serve to
reassure  be conscience together let's
help us to remember that others
are not statistics or numbers the other has a
face
the tool is always a concrete face a
brother to take care of
there is a story that Jesus told
to help understand the difference between
those who do not  it is uncomfortable and whoever takes care
of the other
you have probably heard about it
is the parable of the good samaritan when
they asked jesus who is my
neighbor that is who I should take care of
jesus told this story the
story of a man that thieves  they had
attacked by stolen
abandoned path along the road two
very respectable people of the time a
priest a Levite saw him but
passed by without stopping then
a Samaritan who belonged to
a despised ethnic group arrived and this
Samaritan at the sight of that
wounded man on the ground
did not pass further  like the others as if
nothing had happened
but he had compassion for them he was moved and
this compassion led him to
perform very concrete gestures  I pour oil
and wine on that man's wounds
a tree brought him and paid out of his own pocket
for his assistance the story of the Good
Samaritan and the history of humanity
today on the path of the peoples there are
wounds caused by the fact that in the center
there is money there are things not
people
and there is the habit of those who
believe themselves well not to care for
others, leaving many human beings
whole peoples behind on the ground in the
street
but there are also those who  gives life to a new world by
taking care of others even at one's
own expense in fact said mother
teresa of calcutta
one cannot love if not at one's own expense
we have so much to do and we must do it
together
but how to deal with the evil we breathe
thank god no system
compassion and the ability to react to
evil that arise from the heart of man can cancel the opening to goodness
now you will tell me they are beautiful words
but I am not a Samaritan not even
mother teresa of calcutta instead each
of us  each of us is precious and
irreplaceable in the eyes of God in the
night of the conflicts we are going
through
each of us can be a
lighted candle that reminds us that light prevails
over darkness not the opposite
for us Christians the future has a name
that this name hope to have  hope
does not mean being naive optimists
who ignore the drama of evil and
humanity hope and the virtue of
a heart that does not close in the dark does
not stop at the past does not live in the
present but knows how to see
hope and brings it to tomorrow  open to
coming, hope is a hidden seed of humble life
that however transforms over time
into a large tree and like an
invisible yeast that makes all the
dough grow that gives flavor to all life and
can do a lot because just one
small light is enough  that feeds on hope
and the darkness will no longer be complete
just one man is enough for there to be
hope and that man can be you
then there is another tool is another tool  and
then we become us and when there is us
the hope begins not the one
started with you when there is
a revolution in us the third and
last message that I would like to share
today concerns the revolution the
revolution of tenderness what
is tenderness and  love that becomes close
and concrete is a movement that starts from the
heart reaches the eyes to the ears
to the
hands tenderness and use the eyes to
see the other use the ears to
hear the other to hear the cry
of the little ones of the poor  of those who fear the
future also listen to the
silent cry of our common home
of the contaminated earth is sick
tenderness means using the hands and the
heart to caress the other to
take care of
him tenderness is the language of the
little ones of those in need  of the other a
child becomes fond of and knows his father
and mother for the caresses for the look
for the voice for the
tenderness I like to hear when the father or the
mother  they talk to their little child
when they too become children
talking how he speaks the child
this is the tender age
lowering himself to the level of the other even
god lowered himself in jesus to rise to
our level
this is the road traveled by the good
samaritan
this is  the path traveled by jesus who
is based that has crossed the whole
life of man with a
concrete language of love yes the tenderness and the
path that
the most courageous and strong men and women have walked is not
weakness tenderness and strength and  the
road of solidarity the road of
humility let me say it
clearly the more powerful the
more your actions have an impact on
people the more you are called to be
humble because otherwise power will
ruin you and you will ruin others
in argentina it was said that  power is
like the fasted gene
who makes you dizzy makes
you drunk makes you lose your balance and leads you
to hurt yourself and your  others
if it does not combine it with humility
and tenderness with humility and
concrete love instead the higher power is the
stronger it becomes service and spreads the
good the future of humanity is not only
in the hands of the politicians of the great
leaders of large companies
yes their enormous responsibility
but the future is above all in the hands
of people who recognize each other
as a tool and themselves as part of
one we need from each
other and therefore please
also remember me with tenderness
so that the task that has been
entrusted to me arise for the good of others of
all of you of all of us
thank you
[Applause]